What WilkinsonEyre are interested in,
that the visitors to this gallery should get,
is the sheer wonder of actually, not all just the objects and the technology,
but in a way the emotional connection;
the human experience of Medicine.
And you get it all here.
The first thing visitors will come
across is the three metre
high bronze statue by Marc Quinn;
fantastic focal point; creates the first
vista and can be seen kind of right from the
other side of the Eastern Hall, and this
really puts the visitor and human body
right at the front of the narrative.
So we have, stripped back to the basic
architecture so things that in a sense
were superfluous and somehow didn't look
as if they belong;  we've taken a lot of
things out. But one of the other things
we've done is let the daylight in.
So, you get these changes in pace from light
to dark;  you bring the outside world into
the space. I don't think it should
always be about sort of removing people
from reality and always be about a black box.
One of the key things was to create these vistas
that would draw visitors through
the spaces. And we spent a lot of time
placing objects: open display,
lighting them dramatically or having
mass displays to draw people across,  I
think that's particularly important when
you get to the void over Making the Modern World and you actually see
right across the gallery and are
drawn in by large-scale AV or amazing objects.
We're trying to turn in a sense what's three galleries into one gallery.
So we're going through a
sequence of spaces and in the middle of
them was a big array of lifts and it was
fundamental as to how we could make
the two main parts of the gallery feel
connected and I think we've really
succeeded with that in a number of ways
that we've done it.  One is having a
unifying floor finish running through;
this rather beautiful wooden floor,  and
the other is to actually cloak the lifts
in a whole range of objects.
They act as partly to terminate vistas but
also to take you on to the next thing.
So you feel there is a continuity
here;  which I think that at the outset
looked quite difficult. But we were
always thinking about it.
With this being an object rich gallery,
one of the challenges was how to display
the cases with the appropriate
environmental conditions that they all require.
But also without creating a barrier between the visitor and the objects.
The design of the display cases
have their technical challenges but
we've used non reflective glass,
practically frameless, and so you get
up close and personal with the objects.
Another key element was communicating the themes to the visitor.
We've got a lot of objects and a lot of different themes.
So we worked very closely with the interpretation team and the graphic design team
and came up with the kind of
graphical hierarchy of totems which work
as signals as you go through the
galleries.
Highlighting a particular section focus object or even
key objects within the narratives.
At the far Western End of the gallery we have
another threshold space;  the look and the
feel of this space was in contrast of
the others spaces
as it's meant to feel quite intimate and a space where you can sit and
think about all the stories you've come
across and your journey through the other galleries.
If we design this right and
we get this right in every way that we can,
the gallery will last 20 to 25
years.
And that you'll come in in 20 years time and it will still look quite fresh.
And if we can do that then I think we've really achieved something.